المحيطه تغطي واحدا وسبعين في المئه من
سطح الارض هذه المساحات البارده الهائله
تمتص اكثر من 90 في المئه من الحراره التي
تحبسها انبعاثاتنا من غازات الاحتباس
الحراري
واساسا ثاني اكسيد الكربون قد سجلت
المحيطات حراره قياسيه جديده العام الماضي
حسب ما ذكرت دراسه نشرها الاربعاء فريق
دولي من العلماء
وخلص موعد الدراسه التي نشرت نتائجها مجله
ادفنسس
الى ان المحيطات تستمر في الاحترار على
مستوى العالمي وترتفع درجه حرارتها الان 8
مرات اسرع مما كانت عليه في السنوات ال 25
الماضيه
تخبرنا اتجاهاته درجات الحراره في
المحيطات قصه مدمره للغايه
منذ عقود ونرى تداعيتها الان اذا نظرنا
الى درجات الحراره من سنه الى اخرى او من
عقد الى عقد فهي ترتفع باستمرار وبلا
هواده وهنا سبب اهميه ذلك المحيطات وهي
محركات
مناخيرها يغير انماط الطقس على مستوى
العالم
وهذا سبب حدوثي موجات حر كارثه
وفيضانات القويه وكلما زادت حراره الماء
زاد محتوى الرطوبه بشكل كبير
الى كميات القياسيه من الامطار وليست
مصادفه اننا شهيدنا العام الماضي فيضانات
في باكستان ونيجيريا وتشاد وغيرها وصفت
بغير المسبوقه
علاوه على ذلك فان التسخيله داخل المحيطات
نفسها
قنبله بيئيه موقوته من قتل وتبييض الشعب
المرجانيه والاحياء البحريه المياه
الساخنه تعني ايضا المياه الموسعه مما
يعني ارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر نحن في
طريقنا لارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر بمقدار
متر واحدا بحلول مطلع القرن
ايوه هدد حياه عشرات الملايين من البشر